you told me a bit about why you're here
now let me tell you why I'm here okay
what's my purpose in the room I'm here I
mean I'll give do a lot of things but if
I could make one sort of overarching so
description it's to make you thick
that's why mr. word this is my goal okay
now it wouldn't be an introductory
lesson if I did not do this achieve my
goal in the first lesson so here we go
if you don't have a book get out some
other kind of paper if you do have your
book there open it up I wouldn't give
you a title for this but I do want you
to follow along with me and maybe you
can think of a title of your own later
on now I don't mind what kind of book
you use if you have a great book that's
fine if you don't that's also just great
okay use your laptop okay ah great
question
you will be using your laptops over the
semester I actually have a couple of
questions on technology but I might
leave that for now the bulk of what we
do as Matt you probably for your own
interest will want to do it with a pen
it would be faster and more efficient
just generally speaking there will be
times when we will need the computers
believe me there's some cool
visualizations in graphing and all that
kind of thing but for now get you can
okay all right now I want to stop I will
start with something which I hope will
make you think okay it's that's all
pretty simple I'm definitely gonna need
as we call this makes sense until we get
to the end you'll be like really really
this is this is what I'm okay so let's
start with a series now you don't know
what a series is as a as a math term a
series is we'll call this one s with a
little J a subscript as series is a
string of numbers you have together
that's okay
as we go through I'm gonna be giving
what Saturn ology to you and I'm not
necessarily gonna dwell on lots of it
but just stop me or throw some you know
sharp instrument yes get my attention so
that I tell you what it is okay this
series is a very simple one um it's it's
that letter G there's four Allen made
dr. guy Italian guy named Randy anyway
you can look him up later the series
that he thought about looked like this
very simple one there is one plus one
forever I can't raise your hand if
you've seen this before anyone that's a
yeah you have okay that's right
don't spoil it for everyone else okay
now here's the thing miss dr. Doug what
do you think I means we think that
indicates he just keeps going I'm glad
some of you said infinity infinity is
gonna be something we deal with later on
but I'm just gonna leave after it does
mean it keeps on going forever never
ends okay but we can think about this we
can think about the whole series the
whole sum and we can actually assign it
a value even though it goes on to
forever now my question to you is what
do you think we should if we had to say
we had to define it we had to give a
value to this what value would you give
me hmm what candidates are they whether
you're right or wrong yes yeah well it
is a bit and that's why I'm posing the
question to you we're gonna meet a lot
of paradoxes in your future well let me
give you a suggestion okay I think we
could call the series 1 equal to 1 okay
I'll tell you what look if you just take
the first part this is the one thing
right if I am I skip over this guy
because he's just a bit annoying right I
mean you just think those two together
and they don't make any difference they
cancel each other out
I start my one donut right and then I've
got another pair yeah right well they
they cancel out they also will disappear
not matter right so I'm just left with
that one that I started with that fair
now that's one idea to pull with it
though is that I could just as easily
play the game the other way right
because I can say well I paid up these
two before right what happened a pair of
these two and these two right so if I
start with this 1 minus 1 is 0
ok and then these with 0 as well and the
next ones will be 0 and 0 so sounds like
it's all 0 it's right hmm now I'm gonna
do this a lot to you and I hope you will
get used to it's very uncomfortable to
begin with ok but um it's gonna be for
your benefit and I hope you realize like
it's not you know what
mocking you industry like that okay so
it's just for interest I'm going to
count to three and I'm gonna ask you to
shout out a guess right I've given you
till tuners one or zero right which one
do you think it would be and on the
count of three I'm gonna ask you to all
say it all together the reason why is
because if I ask you like raise hands
and I can think people look at each
other like oh he's smart and he said one
so I'm gonna put one is that what you
know so I don't want to do that that's
what I see what you think okay so the
count of three I want you to say 1 or 0
right and I just want to see where the
balance of the room is like eat seat
ready right you feel about it
I can't count 3 1 2 3 we're almost 50/50
now that you actually said something
right hands up for once I'm just curious
now it's it's okay good that is okay
hands down and hands up for zeros now
okay so it looks like it's sort of stood
at 1/3 2/3 okay I'd like to suggest your
role I don't think it's one or at 0 and
it's partly borne out by thanking you
all disagree with each other okay I
think it's equal to something completely
different and I will show you how I
think it worked no sorry I'm going to
take this series right and I'm gonna
take it away from one I get is good next
name okay 1 minus this series now by the
way I should say this proof that I'm
about to show you it's controversial its
controversial people argue about it all
the time in fact if you guys to my final
result and you go search for it you'll
find a lot of people arguing about
did you know maths can be controversial
sure it can now some people say I could
do this but I'm just gonna give it a go
anyway and see what happens watch I say
1 - and then I've got that whole series
in there coming off to its own it's not
some brackets right because I've got the
whole thing right that's one minus one
plus
plus one minus one and so on forever
okay now you're Stage five okay I think
we can expand brackets by now okay so
tell me what is this going to be equal
to once I expand it don't forget there's
a minus sign out the front the minus
sign out the front means what's going to
happen all the science now loss swap
their loan reverse write every single
one
so therefore this plus one is going to
be a minus one then this minus one will
be plus one and it's going to continue
right
I recognize that I recognize that that's
my first line isn't it this this thing
here on the right hand side this is this
is the series I started with is it not
what do you think have I have I do
anything weird it's just expanding
brackets I think so far so good
okay but hold on what's this thing equal
to it's equal to that right I can do
this
this is algebra it's just it's just it's
got a weird I mean if I just did that
you know it's an essence in under and
you can work out what this is
I'll put the GBA what do I do
suggestions that's something to both
sides okay I just end up with a 1 on
this side and it looks like I get two of
them over here there's two right
do you believe it hmm am I making you
think yet believe me I'm just getting
started
okay all right now where they accept it
or not the logic is there and you can
disagree with the logic if you like but
the logic is there nonetheless okay it
does seem strange but when you look at
all these numbers which are all whole
admittedly somewhat negative but they're
all whole you add them up and somehow a
fraction pops out the other end